what i also appreciate is i actually
recently got to purchase crit was here
on vinyl hey thank you i was at amoeba
and i was surprised to see it hmm yeah
and i was like wait a minute
[ __ ] i don't know if this is bootleg or
not i hope not
but no i mean it was just amazing to be
able to have it out on streaming
platforms for people to listen to it now
i was going to say like i know that was
an uphill battle
oh yeah i mean because you want to it's
not only sample clearances i mean and me
is also the thought process behind not
wanting it to sound
not wanting to lose clean it up too much
wanting people to still get that same
feel some wreckers didn't make it you
know some things had to change but it's
still a blessing man all these years to
be able to put that out and people
actually wanted to listen i'm just happy
that
i don't have to go to that piff anymore
yeah uh yeah on youtube and it cut off
after youtube is the worst yeah so you
know but no we out here man and it's
just to have a catalog is a beautiful
thing too bro 100 and you have a
catalogue over 400 [ __ ] songs you
have 400 songs on dsp's got to got to be
at this point that makes sense yeah so
how many albums officially now that 10
10 albums wow yeah i think uh you know
meena would say 10 yeah so in in in in
still having the
the hunger to do this that's not even
including the little eps you dropped
like four years ago
freestyle shits and all that all the
features combined definitely got a lot
of music out here oh with features
combined you're over 400 oh yeah wild
now